south by southwest you know man that bkx
sw
we had to showcase my dude been hanging
out backstage man
having a good time on some crown royal
out here yeah you already know
i'm just out here living my south by is
done easier
i did my shows yesterday i did my
interviews today so i'm just chilling
trying to experience south by for the
couple hours i got right i met you last
year at south by um
and uh you were like you were selling
out like you know
600 person venues yeah and then i got my
boys in phoenix like yo
[__] is this g eazy guy he sold out
marquee theater yeah
like me we're just trying to get it man
it's been you know what i mean it's
it's kind of like a mentality it's
philosophy towards the world it's like
always stay hungry always keep pushing
yourself
and just you know what i mean the hunger
for more you know it's just like
keep putting everything in place and
keep making the moves to just
take steps forward what do you think has
been like the key to you
um connecting with fans because you're a
perfect example of
of you know a funk volume a macklemore
who who
organically built a fan base and it
turned into a major situation but what
do you think
has been key the key thing that kind of
you knew it's catching on like
right i mean what you just said is
really important to stay organic
um another thing people people take this
for granted but it's like
consistency means so much another thing
is like
identity and just staying true to
oneself
knowing who you are knowing who the
music is knowing who the artist is
and where everything lies you know and
just being consistent with that
and releasing music regularly you know
servicing the fans and just
continuing to build so many people they
reach a certain level
and you know this comfort level starts
to kick in right right you know content
like all right i'm good like
you know like you know i'll be okay as
long as i can i was like yeah
hey i haven't taken care of my mom's yet
i'm not good yet you know what i mean
like you got to keep working you got to
keep
you know what i mean like striving for
more and that's that's really what
drives it
so a little birdie told me that uh if
y'all don't know he's from the bay area
and you might have an e40 on some [__]
hey a little birdie might have just told
you that bruh
hey i woke up the other day to a missed
call for me 40.
and for me a kid growing up in the bay
that's like [__]
e40 is jay-z yeah e40 is jesus you know
i mean like mack trey and e40 are the
two gods like where i come from
so you know when we connected i was just
like star struck to be on the phone with
him
you know so for him to say like you know
i've been hearing the noise about the
music i love the sound i love the song
like
that meant the world to me so you know
he sent me the verse
we we just put it out today man oh [__]
honestly i didn't even
i'm man i'm surprised blogs are people
are putting [__] out today all the
[__] bloggers are getting drunk out
here
that's what they told us it was like yo
it's southpaw man you can't release some
[__] today i was like no
e40 just gave me a verse on my song
we're putting this out today for the
single yeah oh man
that's a big deal bro yeah is that a big
deal talk about the album
um you know uh you would just put out
the
the the last album when i met you last
year yeah
this album you you got the [__]
visuals the balloons at the shows and
all this [__] the aesthetics are real
nice
this album is like everything we wanted
to do on the last one times 10.
you know the time we wanted to take the
effort the attention to detail
you know what i mean like it's really
like this feels like my proper debut
album
to the world you know what i mean wait
it it's your major label debut album
it's it it may be okay okay
all i know is a certain label keeps
blasting me jeezy songs
we're gonna say who it is but jeez he
might have [__] around and got you
know you got some
uh you might have a machine behind him
but it's inevitable
you know what i mean because the
business outgrows itself you know what i
mean you can only keep it
inside a room for so long but at the
same time what matters to me
is the music staying authentic
the the brand the identity the
relationship with the fans and
everything staying true
to everything that we've built for so
long you know a hundred percent man well
yo go get the albums
these things happen it's coming soon
that ambiguous coming soon
but you know it is and um yeah man
congratulations
on future endeavors that might be
announced right now
soon i don't know yo shout out to easy
though bootleg kev you know